[Music]
we seem to have lost a moral will here
in the west there are many other
indicators that we may be trending in
the wrong direction would you agree with
that or do you are you more optimistic
about the future I think we've just
allowed the educational system to move
much further to the left than most
people realize they don't pursue their
own interests as a generation at all
rationally and the new religions of of
the secular sphere turned out to be in
some ways a good deal worse than the
religions they
displaced Neil it's such a pleasure to
have you back on the show uh at a time
when it's a few things are a pleasure I
feel it's it's it's been a difficult
time these last few weeks we're
recording this at ARK um there are
people who say that we are in the last
days of Western Civilization there are
people like R Dal who talk about how
there are six stages of the collapse of
Empire we're in five and a half or
whatever as a historian what do you make
of this um and everything that's been
happening recently well I agree that
it's not a particularly cheerful moment
in world history but in my most recent
book Doom the politics of catastrophe I
try to argue that cyclical theories of
History should be regarded with a great
deal of skepticism because history isn't
cyclical we would love it to be because
of course that would make it so much
easier to understand and indeed to
predict and we would like it to be
cyclical because we as individuals have
a life cycle but history doesn't have a
life cycle Empires civilizations great
Powers they don't and and it's obvious
when you actually look at them seriously
rather than massaging the data to find a
cycle uh if you look at historical long
run historical data the characteristic
feature is a lot of Randomness and that
is because disasters upheavals are not
normally distributed they're they're
actually often either completely random
like the incidents of major Wars or they
are par law driven pandemics earthquakes
that kind of thing so I'm a big skeptic
about cyclical theories of History
Empires rise and fall yes sure but some
Empires rise and fall really fast try
Hitler's Empire which doesn't really get
going until 36 and is done and Rubble by
45 that's 9 years whereas other Empires
think of Rome
you can measure in a millennium so I
don't think it's plausible to say oh
Western Civilization has reached the
fifth stage and Decline and fall are
just around the corner it's fun and it
sells books and there's always a market
in the United States especially for the
impending end of the Republic but it
just doesn't seem to me that history is
like that okay well interesting let me
try from a different angle then because
I think a lot of people might say look
at where we are uh the West has
accumulated huge debts uh the West's
Authority around the world is being
challenged very robustly now to put it
mildly um we seem to have lost a moral
will uh here in the west there are many
other indicators that we may be trending
in the wrong direction would you agree
with that or do you are you more
optimistic about the future a lot of
what you just said is true but you could
also have said that in 1973 so 50 years
ago didn't look great did it because the
United States seemed to be losing the
Cold War basically had bailed on South
Vietnam which 2 years later was gone
puff and uh it wasn't exactly going
swimmingly in the Middle East uh in
October
1973 uh the Soviet Union we know was
going to decline and fall with great
speed in the 1980s that wasn't obvious
in
1973 the inflation problem of 73 was
going to get a lot worse it's
plausibly uh not going to be as bad this
decade and I could go on uh in 1973
America was already in the early phases
of the Watergate disaster which was
would bring Richard Nixon to resignation
to avoid impeachment if you had asked
people 50 years ago how is it going
there would been a lot who' have agreed
uh with the declinist who really thought
the game was up there was a huge amount
of Vision in the United States and not
only in the United States I'm old enough
to remember the 70s it wasn't a
particularly good time in the United
Kingdom either in fact the UK was the
sort of poster child of stagflation at
that time so what am I telling you yeah
that's not a great moment
2023 but I'm not convinced that there's
some great cycle at work here it was
pretty bad 50 years ago too and seven
years later Ronald Reagan's elected nine
years later Berlin Wall comes down and
two years after that the Soviet Union is
gone so the lesson I would like to draw
from history is there's a lot of
nonlinearity and you have to be I think
making a more precise argument than you
just did to get me properly worried so
let me
try so what is worrying today is not
that we feel terribly divided or we're
so polarized it's not particularly I
think that uh there's uh a major
economic problem actually the United
States economy is shockingly strong
under the circumstances I think the
things that are concerning to me are
number
one China Russia Iran North Korea are
working with
increasing uh cooperation and
coordination in ways that are
threatening to a number of democracies
that the United States and its allies
have been backing Ukraine is one Israel
is another Taiwan is probably next and
secondly China's really much bigger
economically it has much greater
resources uh technologically too than
any previous rival that the United
States and its allies faced Soviet Union
econom ically was never more than about
42% of GDP relative to the US well
China's a lot bigger than that certainly
in the 80% range it's above 100% if you
do a purchasing power parity calculation
so that's the second point the third
thing that is I think concerning is that
the United States feels less able to
cope with these geopolitical challenges
than it was say 50 years
ago and I I'll give you one specific
example of that it cannot be right that
with the economy more or less full
employment there is a deficit of 7% of
gross domestic product and that is going
to lead very quickly into some nasty
fiscal
arithmetic in to be specific debt
service costs are about to overtake
defense spending and that trend line is
is really not pretty with interest rates
rising and the deficits EX in excess of
5% of GDP as far as the I can see so I
think the fiscal situation of the US is
a lot worse than it was in 1973 and that
means that the US isn't actually able to
cope with three military crises at once
uh lastly the military industrial
complex ain't what it was God I miss it
I mean there was a time when the US
really was the arsenal of democracy I
made this point some time ago aona in a
Bloomberg column it's quite a bit behind
China which is now the Arsenal of
autocracy with manufacturing value added
roughly 2x that of the United States you
don't have to go back very far for it to
be the other way around back in I think
around 2002 3 4 the US was a a
manufacturing power much greater than
China so in the space of two decades
there's been a real role reversal in the
event of a hot war with China the US
would run out of precision missiles in
about 5 days more or less that's a much
worse situation than anything 50 years
ago so there are reason to be worried
but I think you have to be quite precise
about what you're worried about and
that's what I'm worried about Neil let's
broaden it this topic out a little bit
how does civilizations actually
fall well that's a good question I think
most people
imagine in a toin Basque way some kind
of inner
crisis of will of morale of
self-belief they think of it as a
perhaps a sort of aging process or maybe
it's just entropy at
work if one looks at the decline and
fall of the Roman Empire in Gibbon's
telling it's really a very protracted
process so protracted as to have been
imperceptible I think for most
contemporaries but in more recent
tellings uh Brian Ward Perkin for
example actually the Roman Empire fell
apart fell apart quite fast especially
the Roman Empire in the west and I think
it was perceptable that Civilization had
sort of come unstuck and I think we can
understand similar processes if one
looks for example in Chinese history the
Ming fell apart in uh the mid 17th
century in a way that was very
perceptible with very meaningful impacts
on quality of life so we know what it's
like when a civilization Falls part the
infrastructure stops working Public
Health gets much worse it can be caused
by War it can be caused by plague it can
be caused by uh other forces that are
perhaps less discernable for example uh
a civilization can fail fiscally it can
fail because its monetary system doesn't
work and it stops being able to uh
deliver surpluses to to the the
population so I think we understand a
little bit how that process
works and when you uh look at the work
of someone like Peter Turin there is an
attempt through his cliodynamics to to
construct models of civilizational
breakdown and and then look for a
contemporary uh analogy and and in his
most recent book Peter argues that the
United States is in this kind of uh of a
cycle uh he emphasizes the
overproduction of Elites too many people
with you know University degrees not
enough for them to do uh he I thought
quite brilliantly forecast a sort of
peak in in organized violence in 2020
which I guess he got lucky with the
pandemic and and George Floyd and the
subsequent Mayhem but it kind of looks
quite good as a prediction right now I I
guess when you look at all his
variables however you could make a
similar argument about China in fact one
of the variables demographics looks
worse for China another of the variables
overproduction of educated people looks
worse for China so in my review of his
book which I like I mean I respect his
work very much I said might be true uh
but it might turn out to be true of
China more a bit like Paul Kennedy's
Book you you might remember the the rise
and fall of the great Powers which came
out in
1987 and said there's a kind of law of
of decline where if you're spending too
much on one thing and not enough on
defense then your industrial capacity
declines and all of that was supposed to
apply to the United States but it turned
out to be more true of the Soviet Union
so we we can look for these signs of uh
unraveling but I think we have to be
quite careful not to be so sure that
it's a US problem that we miss other
worst problems
elsewhere I think the US also has a has
a kind of
interesting track record of worrying
about its own decline I think it's a
feature not a bug of the United States
to worry about decline or to worry that
the Republic's somehow going to enter a
terminal crisis or that American power
is going to Wayne Americans love
worrying about that it's one of the
things that sells books and gets op-eds
printed and then it happens to the other
guy and and Americans are like gee we
won and then there's the kind of
euphoric decade before it's it's time to
start worrying about decline again do
you not think as well Neil that one of
the signs that a civilization is in
collapse is they no longer believe in
the shared myth of the Empire and do not
worry about that with America where it
seems that there doesn't seem to be as
many people particularly in the elites
who believe in the project anymore well
it depends what you mean by the project
Americans have never been comfortable
with the idea of empire for the Fairly
obvious reason reason that their project
is an anti-imperial one uh to begin with
so when the United States exercises
power it's an empire in denial this was
the theme of a book I did 20 years ago
Colossus and I think that book was right
about American power it's it's not
something that can be exercised in the
way that say British power was or in
fact the way that most empires have
exercise power because Americans are in
denial about having that kind of power
when they go into Mesopotamia or or into
you know Afghanistan somehow it's not
Empire but when anybody else does it it
is so this is a strange thing it means
that the American project doesn't have
as clear a mandate for Global policing
as other past Empires the American
project is really about being a shining
City on a Hill building a kind of uh
Republic which is just the best one and
everybody should be filled with with
admiration and want to copy it and I
think that project is definitely a
project that is losing the confidence
especially of Young Americans fast and
they've been aided and ab bettered in
losing confidence by the education
system which is absolutely full of
people from the elite of Harvard down to
the lowliest uh kindergarten saying that
the American project was bad it was
founded on white supremacist see in
generally speaking most of American
history as a tale of Woe that kind of
argument is really quite widely believed
by young people so I think if if the
project is The Shining City on a Hill
the model for all democracies that
project has lost a lot of uh belief
particularly amongst young
people whether they continue to feel
that way as they get older is an
interesting question by and large people
are quite inclined to stick with the
views they form in their student years
it's surprising how untrue it is that
people are kind of lefties when they're
young and then they're sort of mugged by
reality and become conservatives that
actually tends not to be true there's
quite a lot of continuity in the way
people think about the world and your
views are often formed by some major
event that occurred when you were in
University um I I worry a little bit
about Generation Z As Americans say
their views are on a whole range of
issues very very different from the
views of older Americans and I suspect
they won't radically change their
worldview as they become more
influential turn up and vote more
regularly become a larger share of the
population as the 65s and older die off
and that could be a big issue this
fundamental skepticism about the
American project that's been inculcated
in in this Young Generation can you
flesh that out for us what do gen edas
believe that we don't
well if you I mean let's just take an
example that I've been looking at
recently if you ask Americans about the
crisis in Israel uh about the attacks
from Gaza and and the Israeli response
the general public is pro-israel older
Americans are very pro-israel but if you
ask Generation Z they're strongly Pro
Palestinian like 11% of them are with
with Israel and I don't know 37 % are
are actually with Palestinians that's a
huge shift there are other shifts too if
you ask Generation Z uh what's your
preference Socialism or capitalism close
to you know 51 52% will say actually we
Pro socialism [__] me sorry somebody who
has experienced socialism we both have
yeah well I mean I I grew up in the west
of Scotland which had the nearest thing
to socialism that was on offer in the UK
but then spent time in the 1980s in the
Soviet Union and in East Germany yeah I
mean I share your exploitive
deleting that's what's going on and and
and and I I could go on it's interesting
that on issues of the environment Young
Americans and young Europeans are
willing to contemplate quite
authoritarian Solutions because they
feel that the planet is dying and we've
only got 10 more years to save it and
therefore drastic measures are warranted
so and yasham monka has been making the
argument for some time that there's a
lot of illiberalism amongst the young
and and that that I think is is
concerning it's not surprising though
because if one actually looks at the
ways in which they're
educated there's a real predominance
of content that is more indoctrination
than
education people uh underestimate the
extent to which even quite young
children are
being taught to believe that the United
States was founded on white supremacy or
that the planet has is being killed and
the only way to stop it dying is zero
growth I mean these ideas are quite
widespread and so one can't sort of say
there something terribly wrong with
Generation Z I think we've just allowed
the educational system to move much
further to the left than most people
realize I had lunch today with a uh an
old friend who uh is a little older than
me me and and went to Princeton I
suppose he he must have been there in
the in the
1970s and I found it quite hard to
persuade him that his son won't have the
same experience that he had there's a
lot of denial about how far Princeton or
Yale or Harvard have swung to the left
amongst people who haven't had that much
to do with you know University life
since they they graduated so I think
there's something going on here which is
pretty worrying if you if you tell Young
Americans or for that matter uh young
British kids as happens you know your
your history your country's history is
is actually quite bad I mean the United
States founded on white supremacy
Britain basically slavery Industrial
Revolution slavery if you tell those
stories unsurprisingly impressionable uh
school children think Li me that's
that's that's history and we should you
know we should really feel quite bad
about that that's H that's happening and
it it it happens with parents not quite
noticing a lot of people noticed during
the pandemic because they they kind of
overhearing the zoom classes and
thinking a
minute what did what did he just say and
I'll I'll give you an illustration of of
what goes on that this is of course
something that I pay a lot of attention
to and I'm sure a few parents do but at
the school that my uh Sons were
attending in
California there was a proposal to to
have a a a module on slavery kind of
part of uh civics or whatever social
studies and I said good I think it's
important that you should teach this
part of American and indeed world
history but I'd be curious to know what
teaching materials you will use and the
teacher very obligingly sent me them and
I did a little bit of research
and looked at these teaching materials
and tried to trace their Providence and
it turned out that they in fact
originated with the Southern Poverty Law
Center which is one of the most
crooked
despicable rackets that ever emanated
from the civil rights movement and it
has made uh a business for itself in
recent years by compiling lists of uh of
islamophobes and white supremacists and
they really set themselves up as witch
finders general for the dreaded right
and and one of their lists actually
included my wife aan hery Ali she was in
the list of of islamophobes there wasn't
there wasn't a comparable list of
Islamic extremists mind you that they
didn't have a list anyway so I looked a
little more closely at the materials
thinking this is a this is a strange
source for teaching materials for
children and sure enough uh when I got
to the takeaways cuz you always have
takeaways in the teaching plan the
takeaways included the United States was
founded on white supremacy and the
situation of African-Americans today is
a little different from their situation
under Jim Crow now I wrote to the
teacher and I said I don't think these
are appropriate teaching materials at
all this is not history this is this is
political uh activism and to her credit
she saw my point and they didn't use
them but unless I had been unless I'd
bothered to do that I might not have
noticed and I think most parents
actually aren't aware of what kind of
thing gets done as history now they just
assume it's pretty much what it was like
when they were at school history was
boring and you in Britain you did kings
and queens if you're in the United
States you did uh Lincoln or George
Washington it's not like that anymore
that's all been changed in the same way
that history at the major universities
has greatly changed in in the nature of
its its content so we have a generation
that I don't think has the same
relationship to history as as even you I
mean you're much younger than me even
you did cuz this is all of relative
relatively recent Providence things have
moved quite fast in the last 10 years
we'll be back with our guest in a minute
but first we want to take a moment to
talk about our partners give send go if
you need to raise funds online but don't
want to hand over your money to fais Big
Tech corporations then giv and go is a
place to do it giv and go is a leading
crowdfunding website where thousands of
people in the US the UK Australia and
Canada raise funds for anything from
business ventures and medical expenses
to personal needs churches and funeral
costs on giv and go you can raise money
for whatever you need we've met the
people at GI and go and we can tell you
that they're absolutely aligned with us
here at trigonometry on our approach to
free speech they've proved time and
again they won't cave to the Mob they
don't just talk the talk they walk the
walk unlike other big tech companies and
that's why we are proud to partner with
them Z like us believe that with
openness and honesty we'll create more
understanding and ultimately more
Harmony in the world GI and go is
absolutely free to use with other
crowdfunding sites you'll pay between 5
and 10% of the money you raise GI and go
charges no money at all to use their
platform they believe you should be able
to keep all the money that you raise
starting a campaign on give Sendo is
easy and intuitive go to give send
go.com today that's give send go.com to
start raising money for whatever's
important to you and now back to the
interview it's a really profound point
because I went to an exhibition at the
British museum about Divinity and uh the
the female in
Divinity and they were describing this
one I think it was a Hindu goddess from
3,000 years ago as being gender
fluid yeah
and I was going being
transphobic and I was I I just couldn't
believe it because this is the British
museum well I didn't go to that
exhibition uh and I I suppose I suppose
it's conceivable that that that that
that's true I I I'm not going to get
drawn into a bitter argument about
gender
fluidity uh in Hindu iconography what I
think goes on a lot
is
anachronistic labeling by which I mean
our approach to the past has shifted
from what I believe it should be which
is that we should understand the past in
its own terms try to understand how
people thought in the past to understand
it uh to a a judgmental mode in which we
go to the Past in order to look down on
uh previous generations for their racism
or uh for for their sexism or whatever
it is and this desire to use terminology
from the 21st century in framing uh
historic objects or indeed historical
narratives I think is extremely negative
and and it's actually contrary to the
spirit of true historical scholarship
the mission of the historian RG
Collingwood made this argument many
years ago in the 1930s is to try to
reconstitute past thought the mental
experience of past Generations as best
we can from what they've left behind and
by kind of process of imagination as
well as careful reconstruction and and
then to juxtapose that past experience
with our own not to say how much worse
that past experience was not to say TTT
how Wicked 18th century people were for
their Notions of uh of of race or their
their willingness to use unfree labor
but to understand it to try to see the
way the world was seen by those now long
dead people it might also help us to
realize that that there is a great deal
of unfree labor in the world today but
very little of it in say uh the British
ISS of North America so this process
where we regard the role of the history
teacher as being essentially to pass
judgment on the values of the past I
think is completely conceived and uh
it's the condescension towards posterity
that I thought we were trying to get
away from as historians uh Neil uh you
talk about gen Z and their education uh
I grew up in a crumbling Empire uh in
the Soviet Union which also attempted to
indoctrinate his children uh but I don't
remember I remember my parents warning
me you know you're going to go to school
and you're going to be taught all this
crazy stuff so get ready they're going
to tell you about pavic maros and
they're going to tell you about this and
that and whatever and by the time I
arrived at school I was rather
inoculated and and many young people
were and as comedians we know that uh I
think ideas are like jokes and that in
order for them to really land with the
listener there has to be something about
their experience that matches what
they're being told and I wonder if you
think that the economic circumstances
facing young people the extraordinary
price of housing for example the
inability therefore to pair up have
families um the sense that many people
now have that they're almost certainly
not going to benefit from the the sort
of liberal Democratic capitalistic
promise which is that we will live
better than our parents is that why
these ideas are as persuasive as they
are to young people today it's possible
though I
think one has to be a bit careful about
about inferring that that young people
are are protesting
uh in support of Hamas because they
can't get onto the housing ladder in
London I mean it's possible you made my
argument sound ridiculous which I think
is slightly unfair no I didn't I didn't
mean to do that what I meant to say was
that that the radicalism of the young
extends along quite a broad front what's
interesting is that it doesn't really
focus terribly much on the economic
issue that you mentioned if if young
people really were concerned about uh
the cost of housing in say the southeast
of England
uh then you'd have thought that they'd
spend a lot of time researching housing
policy and campaigning for reductions in
the green belt and the construction of
War housing but they do the exact
opposite they oppose that because their
radical support for
environmental uh movements Extinction
Rebellion Etc uh actually points them in
the opposite direction and you'll find
young people tying themselves to trees
to stop further development in the green
belt so I I don't think if if these
economic issues are are what's at work
that that young people are are pursuing
their own interest very competently no
they're not but let me make the the
connection that I was trying to make and
perhaps you can address where the
nihilism is therefore coming from
because uh the argument I would make is
if you don't have a bright future as you
perceive it it is quite natural to
retreat into some kind of cope as people
now say on the internet yeah and the
cope might be that we care about things
that we can't control because we can't
control the things that we care about
I.E housing I mean I can tell you even
for Our Generation the housing issue is
massive and no amount of researching
greenbell policies going to get someone
my age on the housing ladder if they're
not already at this point and we know
obviously as you do and I do that
becoming a parum for example massively
changes how you see the world so there's
actually getting on a property ladder
Young people who to whom that's not
available are quite likely to uh tend
towards nihilism I would argue you
disagree perhaps so where is denialism
coming from if not from there well I
think there is a a couple of points that
are worth making first is
if if young people are suffering from
the consequences of policies that have
essentially rigged uh the property
Market or the economy more broadly in
favor of old
Generations uh then they ought to be
attracted to the more radical proposals
uh not just to reform the housing uh
situation but also to reform the welfare
state because the the main problem that
young people face is that the
intergenerational uh balance is simply
not being maintained the liabilities of
welfare states in most Western countries
uh hugely skewed in favor of the elderly
it's the young who will pick up the tab
for the very generous forms of welfare
that the Baby Boomers essentially voted
for themselves and so if we're about
economics you'd have thought that more
young people would be as haek wrongly
predicted uh arguing for radical reform
of entitlements I mean Hayak even says
in the constitution of Liberty that the
young will finally get so impatient with
the elderly that they'll kind of her
them into camps none of that has
happened the young defer unwittingly I
think but they defer to the logic of the
welfare state young are overwhelming on
the left they support uh labor of the
conservatives Democrats of Republicans
massively but that's bizarre because
actually labor and the Democrats are the
people most committed to preserving the
welfare state with its current transfers
from the relatively young to the elderly
so I don't think young people understand
their economic interests at all well now
you may be right that faced with this uh
problem they Retreat into nalism because
they can't bring themselves to do what
would be rational which would be to
support uh the center for policy studies
position on housing or you know the
position of Republicans or older uh
position of Republicans for entitlement
reform they may justat into nihilism
because embracing those conservative
Solutions is just too odious to them
there is another possibility though
which is that they are as I was trying
to argue drawn into a series of
ideological positions through their
education and these ideological
positions lead to what used to be called
on the left false consciousness they
think the problem is uh Big Oil they
think the problem is capitalism uh they
think the problem is uh settler
colonialism because they get given these
phrases from school and in University
and and the net effect is that they
don't pursue their own interests as a
generation at all rationally and I made
this I made this point in the great
degeneration back in 2012 that if the
young really understood their
self-interest in the US they would all
have been in favor of Paul Ryan's uh
program of entitlement reform but almost
no young people voted for Mitt Romney
and Paul
Ryan Neil do you think part of the
problem is as well is that these
narratives that they're fed particularly
when it comes to history are so
incredibly powerful and they're so
simplistic that they're far easier to
ingest than actually what is a very
unpleasant truth is as my dad always
likes to tell me there's no black and
white lad there's only a murky shade of
gray well I do think I can see why you
came out the way
didn't it's a good point my soul is from
Wigan yeah I mean the think having grown
up in in Glasgow I was receptive to that
kind of argument too when the entire
city is gray uh it seems quite plausible
and there aren't that many moments in
history when you can say
unequivocally Good Guys bad guys I made
this point in the war of the world that
we end up winning World War II with
Stalin doing a huge amount of the
fighting and hardly need to tell you
this but the Soviet Union is as brutal
as a totalitarian regime as Nazi Germany
and so even that's a tainted victory
that and that's one of the things that
an older generation have long clung to
is the one thing we did that was
absolutely right except from the vantage
point of people in Eastern Europe it was
anything but that so I think it's partly
that the stories are attractive the
story of the imminent end of the world
is one of the most attractive there is
uh that that's been a part of of the
great monotheistic religions people are
drawn to disastrous outcomes it's why
science fiction is a prop popular genre
and so if you tell people that there is
this imminent Extinction of end and the
day after tomorrow everything's just
going to be on fire and it be dying from
climate change it very people are very
receptive to that kind of argument and
it's it's quite hard to argue against it
because it's it's approached in quasi
religious spirit so if you offer any
kind of criticism you're a denier
heretic a blasphemer so people are drawn
into what is in fact a kind of secular
religion of the impending end of days
and we must prepare for it how should we
prepare for it by fasting so we become
vegans we should be celibates we
shouldn't have children and so you
essentially have a kind of secular
religion and this is something that
vline and others saw as a problem in the
20th century that in in the wake of the
predominance of
Christianity people didn't believe in
nothing they believed in anything and
and the new religions of of the secular
sphere turned out to be in some ways a
good deal worse than the religions they
displac well we're here again with the
kind of strange religion of the
impending end of the world and I think
it's just it is much more appealing than
it's complicated which is you know the
least exciting combination of words and
and the thing that historians are
compulsively driven to say at the
beginning of almost any answer they give
to a question I I do think there is
black and white though and here I'm
going to come back at
Wigan I think there is a very profound
difference between a free society in
which one can speak freely and write uh
what one thinks and meet and form
associations with whomever one likes and
an unfree society in which those things
are highly dangerous and indeed
prohibited and may lead you into uh a
jail even a labor camp that's a really
big difference what is wrong with kids
today I know I do sound like the old uh
fart that I've become is that they have
no very clear idea of what an unfree
Society is like hence queers for
Palestine you know when radical funder
by the way we're going to send them all
over we've got a t-shirt for you now
it's um it's kind of bizarre and I've
always said it was bizarre I mean I I
remember saying to to my wife when we
lived in Cambridge Massachusetts
wouldn't it be funny if all the people
who hate me and all the people who you
simultaneously protested outside our
house and the islamists found themselves
right next to the you know the trans
activist how would that go we'd be able
to sneak out the back as they fell on
one another uh it's it's a curious thing
that that the people don't understand
what it's like to live under Hamas and
they don't really understand what the
Iranian Revolution aspires to do they
don't understand what it was like to
live in Stalin Soviet Union or in M
China if they understood that then they
might be more reluctant to do the kind
of things that many students are tempted
to do these days like write letters of
denunciation call for people to be fired
for things that they've said it's
amazing how totalitarian behaviors can
creep into a free society and I think
we've just failed to communicate
unfreedom as a phenomenon to this
generation and and maybe that's just uh
our bad as a generation that we didn't
get across to the Generation Z kids what
it was like and I I kind of used to toy
with the idea of you know trips to North
Korea cuz I don't think you ever feel
quite the same about Freedom once you've
been in an unfree unfree Society exactly
and this is I think why we started
trigonometry and been talking to so many
people about it because we both know
what that's like from our various
experiences I was going to ask you as
you were talking right at the end about
this because do you think this maybe is
a cyclical element of History it seems
that these ideas um mutated as they are
are essentially what we had in the
Soviet Union but along slightly
different
lines and it just takes a couple of
generations for for us to forget and
then we're back to square one and then
the power of these ideas is they sound
so good good all things to all men
equality blah blah blah blah blah is it
just you know three generations and bam
we're back to square one well I think
the kind of Amnesia cycle of history
that you know you you your your
grandfather actually fought my
grandfather's fought in the world wars
uh and my father and my mother very
clearly remembered being children in
that time and I uh grew up in the 1960s
and 1970s with the war as this sort of
uh ubiquitous uh Collective memory which
even constructed how we played in the
playground and and after a certain point
it just sort of wears off and you know
I'll give you an example I don't think
anybody watches black and white movies
anymore whereas I did I can't get my
children to watch them but if you don't
watch black and white movies it's really
quite hard to properly to connect with
the second world war because so much of
the great World War II movies are are
black and white so that may be true I
think the role of the historian the role
as as I understand it is to counter that
Amnesia by as vividly as possible
conveying what the experience of the
Bolshevik Revolution and its aftermath
were like and I think those of us who do
the job seriously I'm thinking here of
Frank dutta's work on China under Mao or
Orlando FES and for him Richard pipes on
the Russian Revolution the people who do
the job well can transcend the Amnesia
of the fourth generation by saying yeah
I know it's a long time ago and you
don't even you never even met your
great-grandfather who was fighting the
Germans or fighting the Japanese but you
need to know
this I don't know quite why we failed so
miserably when for a time it felt as if
Hitler and Henry VII were what kids in
British schools were taught
somehow all that teaching about the
Holocaust has failed if there are
Generation Z students chanting from The
River To The Sea Palestine will be free
apparently oblivious to the fact that
that implies a second Holocaust so you
kind of find yourself asking where did
all that Holocaust history get us we we
clearly didn't get the message across
about why Hitler was bad that that that
somehow got Lost in
Translation do you have a website or do
you plan to have a website because if
you do then easy DNS is a company for
you easy DNS is the perfect domain name
registar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients whether it be cancel
culture D platform attacks or
overzealous government agencies he knows
about that so will you in a second easy
DNS have Rock Solid Network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that move
your domains and websites over to easy
DNS right now all you've got to do is go
to easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com triggered use our promo code
which is also triggered and get 50% off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and
censorship you think part of the problem
is is that we get talk about the
Nazis but we just associate
anti-Semitism with the Nazis and that's
it so we so as a result of that young
people only see anti-Semitism through
that particular lens and then they can't
make the connections elsewhere that may
be rise uh that that in a sense we've
compartmentalized it so that well that
was that was the Nazis and it somehow
doesn't apply to Palestinian Islamic
Jihad uh I I guess that's possible but I
do feel as if collectively there's been
a huge failure in historical education
and if we' done a better job there would
be a greater allergy to symptoms of
totalitarian ISM such as calls for uh
Israel to be wiped from the map or the
kind of uh the kind of propaganda the
emonics from Iran we should be young
people should be much more allergic to
that than they seem to be and that I
think may be because in in teaching the
history of the Third
Reich we failed not just to make clear
that it had a general relevance I mean
I've always felt that a really important
feature of uh historiography to counter
is the notion of a German special way
that somehow it could only really have
happened in Germany and a lot of my
early work was designed to to make uh
the exact opposite point that there was
nothing really that different about
Germany and uh it could have happened
elsewhere that that's a central theme of
The War of the world that the ideas that
Hitler uh bundled together are not made
in Germany the ideas about misation come
from the United States the ideas about
hereditary disease requiring to be
controlled by sterilization that had
actually been put into action in the
United States before Hitler came to
power so we need I think we failed to
convey that there was a general problem
which Hitler exemplified we turned it
into a German problem which Hitler
exemplified and the second thing I think
that we fail to do is to come up with a
explanation of Hitler's rise that was
really compelling and convincing there
are lots of theories about the rise of
Hitler and they get toed to uh children
at least at least in some schools still
today and it's usually well there was
this terrible economic crisis and
unemployment went up very high and then
then the Nazis came to power uh that's a
kind of standard school textbook version
It's really unconvincing because
unemployment went Skyhigh in the United
States as well and they got Roosevelt I
don't think that the explanations for
the rise of Hitler have worked at all
well the conventional mainstream
explanations that we used to teach uh
children because the truth of this the
story is that the viar Republic had this
very perfect Constitution it was very an
impressive intellectual achievement it
was designed to be the leading welfare
state uh of the world and it it failed
disastrously it produced first
hyperinflation and then a crashing
depression this alienated many middle
class Germans from the whole project of
democracy and it made them highly
susceptible to a charismatic leader
whose critical feature was that he was
the most gifted de demagogue of of
modern times not enough of the recent
scholarship on Hitler emphasizes that
point the Demonic power of His
oratory uh and the personality cult that
quickly formed around him that's the
really interesting thing there were lots
of fascist parties Europe had fascist
parties just about in every country none
of them other than Germany had Hitler
and so the real sort of story is not
that Germany had very high employment it
the story is that it had the most
charismatic demonic of all the fascist
leaders and we ought to therefore be
really worried about Charisma as a force
in politics because it can so easily
lead even a highly educated people which
the Germans certainly were in the 19
early 1930s down a path that goes really
fast from uh an election Victory to aitz
that's the lesson that I don't think we
properly conveyed Thomas H makes the
very same point I think in Black
rednecks and white liberals has a whole
chapter on the Germans yeah excuse me
and he makes the same point I want to
ask you a couple of um unrelated things
to the end of the world uh or the
everything is related to the end of well
not everything uh I'm curious I don't
know if you saw this I don't know how
much you use social media there has been
a meme going around of women asking
their Partners male Partners how often
they think about the Roman Empire and it
turns out that the average man allegedly
thinks about it about 73 times a
day wasn't quite as often as that I'm
exaggerating for comedic purposes uh but
uh why do you think we care so much
about the Roman Empire why is it such an
interest to us here at least in the
west well first of all I highly doubt
that men think about the Roman Empire
that frequently and I'm deeply skeptical
about whatever research produced this
meme uh because it implies that that men
think at
all about anything Ferguson's a feminist
now I'm not sure that that there's all
that much thinking going on about about
any Empire or indeed about anything much
beyond the football
no to be
serious in the case of the United
States uh which I think is where the
research came from Rome is this implicit
point of
comparison and it's there in in the
architecture the project was in in some
ways uh as much a Roman as an Athenian
want to create a a republic and so
Americans have this uneasy feeling that
might be Rome and there's lots of books
and articles that feed that theory not
to mention movies from uh Kirk Douglas
to Russell Crow it's quite surprising
how much Roman content Hollywood
produced over the decades so I think
that's why in the United States the
Roman Empire keeps coming up you only
need to go to Washington to see what is
it about this architecture that seems
familiar that's probably why I I doubt
very much that i' be very skeptical that
the average Englishman thinks about the
Roman Empire once a day or even once a
year and why is it that it's a Roman
Empire we tend to talk about and not the
Greek Empire because pretty Cogan
argument can be made that these are
where these ideas originated from well I
think uh you only need to look at the
Hollywood uh list of books about ancient
Greece to see why there aren't many uh
Rome has uh I think a more
straightforward uh
storyline I mean the pipian war there
must be a reason it's not been a big
Hollywood
hit I think part of what's
straightforward about the Roman story is
that the Republic flips to Empire once
and the Empire then produces a fantastic
Rogues gallery of monstrous and
memorably monstrous emperors and so the
I Claudius factors there in a way that
it just isn't with uh the Greek
demagogues so I think the Greeks just
lost out when it came to villains I mean
they just where where is the Nero where
is the
cular uh so it's a more straightforward
moral story uh it's more recent and also
I mean Athens
[Music]
Rome I mean with all due respect to my
Greek friends Rome Just wins as a
tourist destination it's got It's got
just the most
staggering things and I don't think the
Acropolis can can match the Coliseum I
took my younger Sons to Rome last year
for a mini Grand Tour and the Coliseum
just blew them away as it should it's a
truly astonishing thing all the baths of
carala or Trent forum and wandering
around Rome one has a very strong sense
of the durability of the Roman Empire I
mean the buildings are still there and
they're they're really really striking
for their scale and and the duration of
of the achievement one doesn't I don't
get quite that same feeling uh from
going to Athens well ironically it is
the Greek colonies in what is now Italy
in Sicily that are much more impressive
I mean if you go to agento the Valley of
the temples is true you get a scale
experience there but yes I mean when you
walk out of the metro and see the
Coliseum yes that is it's an
unforgettable experience um and Carthage
why do we not talk about Carthage at all
is it because the Romans essentially
flattened and destroyed it yeah that was
that was a win they set out to do that
and they they they did achieve it I
think that's the pro probably the most
the archetypal example of History being
written uh by the winners and
the one thing that has endured well not
the one thing many things have endured
about the the Greek the GRE the ancient
Greek Empire which I I love reading
about and when I was a teacher I used to
teach the kids and you could see that
they had a magic to it which was the
myths yeah it's something that speaks to
us why why do you think that is why why
is Greek mythology even now so
incredibly powerful I remember as a
school boy thinking well hang on a
second the Romans just took all the
Greek gods and named them and so the
Greek gods were the real gods and and
Rome was just engaged in rebranding and
I think that's that's probably part of
it the first school book I ever won as a
prize was the Greek uh myths and so
there is something uh compelling about
that and it wasn't where the Romans were
at all
Innovative uh the Greeks of course left
this great literary Legacy which again
the Romans could only kind of copy cuz
the need it's really just a knockoff uh
so I think in cultural terms if you
think at all about the ancient world you
have to sort of take your hat off uh to
the Greeks for being the true innovators
but of course if if what you're
interested in is is is power then
somehow Rome's has this greater uh
range definitely territorially ranged
further and more enduring more enduring
monuments I wasn't an ancient historian
I I hasten to add I in in my time modern
history of Oxford just meant not ancient
so I did a lot more medieval in early
modern history than than ancient history
which I I suppose I now I now regret uh
but I I I think I think that's that's
the real story I do wish that we did
more to teach
today's students about the ancient world
because one of the things that's most
impressive to me is that the Greek and
Roman political philosophy provide very
important building blocks for
understanding what we mean when we talk
about western
civilization and and the idea that there
are these inherent problems with
Republican government that may likely
lead to tyranny it's such a fundamental
idea the Renea saurce is about sort of
taking that idea and dusting it down
breathing new life into it then it
becomes absolutely fundamental to
Enlightenment thinking I that's such an
important idea and it's one that I keep
reminding my American friends about
because it's quite plausible that the
Republic won't last indefinitely and
it's going down a path that seems
familiar to any student of classical
Western political philosophy where uh
the the Republic becomes corrupt it
benefits the elite ordinary plebs become
disillusioned and a demagogue comes
along and says look the whole thing is a
racket but if you give all the power to
me I'll put things right I mean that's
what's going to play out next year in
the United States Americans should be
worried about that whether they're
conservatives or or liberals they should
understand that the most obvious threat
to the Republic apart from defeating War
by a foreign power the most obvious
threat is the demagogue who says I alone
can fix this and clearly has no regard
for the Constitution at all I mean
that's what Trump is he is ex exactly
what the founding father's worried about
and he's here why do you say that Neil
that you are on the right I I would I
think a lot of people would say and yet
um Donald Trump is a creature of the
right as it is
now there are a lot of people who think
genuinely he's the only person who can
fix the problems of America because he
comes from outside of the political
realm uh because he's not beholden to
donors um I mean your argument about his
disregard for the Constitution I think I
think after his comments about the
election last time is strong people
would argue Hillary Clinton said the
same thing Donald Trump is an
illegitimate president they invented the
Russia collusion hoax and ran with it
for years both sides are denying
elections why is Donald Trump special is
it because he's more
charismatic I think there are a couple
of points to make one I entirely agree
that the delegitimation of election
results was not something that Trump
began it was it was was used against him
in 2016
2017 uh and I think that the Democrats
and and they've done it again I think uh
have brought this upon themselves by
their almost complete disregard for the
the concerns of of so many ordinary
Americans about illegal
immigration uh and crime they they'
played into Trump's
hands and in some ways the first Trump
Administration was a successful
Administration that addressed a great
many of the problems that ordinary
Americans had had been frustrated by
I'll give you one simple example if you
look at real median household earnings
they completely flatlined from 1999
right the way through until 2016 they
did not move at all and under Trump they
Rose 9% in real terms just in three
years and even the pandemic could not
undo that
gain the problem with a second Trump
term is that on January the 6 I think he
revealed himself to be a real enemy of
constitutional government in ways that
ought really to have disqualified him
for future office I said that at the
time I urged friends who were in the
administration to resign immediately I
still think it was a
catastrophic but revealing moments in
American history and to reelect a man
who's acted in that way is is an almost
suicidal step for anyone who believes in
in constitutional government I do I
think the Constitution is sacred and and
the president's role is to uphold it I
don't think Donald Trump can be trusted
to uphold the Constitution or indeed any
contract that he's ever signed so I
don't think that's an unconservative
position I think it's a truly
conservative position uh it's tragic
that American voters are going to be
confronted with the same choice that
they were confronted uh with in
2020 Joe Biden is a even less credible
uh candidate because of his age and
mistakes that the Biden Administration
has made at the moment I feel as if
events are are playing into Trump's
hands and I think the lesson of history
is that republics that go down that
path are dicing with death I mean
there's we could always get Gavin Newman
you'd be happy with that that wouldn't
you KN well I wouldn't be happy with
this but I think if I were a Democrat
that's what I would do I mean I really
would and I've said this to my
Democratic friends that if you're really
serious about stopping Trump you can't
possibly think that Joe Biden and camela
Harris Can Do it a second time and so
you really ought to try uh to to lead
the old man off stage and and clear the
way for somebody uh as utterly cynical
and unprincipled as Gavin yum who's
probably
capable of beating Trump but I don't
think that's going to happen at least
it's it's very late in the day for it to
happen now so yeah I think I think
coming back to our doleful start if
there's one thing that worries me about
Western Civilization it's the
possibility that its most important
component today the United States
commits a sort of political suicide uh
it it certainly would be in line with
much of classical and Renaissance an
Enlightenment political theory that that
would happen and here I think I agree
with with Peter Turin I think we are
approaching a crisis in the United
States but I think it's more a crisis of
Republican constitutional order and its
legitimacy than a crisis of the
overproduction of Elites or demography
or any of that kind of stuff I just
think this is the classical problem that
that republics run into after a certain
point when the legitimacy of the
Constitution is no longer
Sac uh well we finished where we started
sadness and misery so Francis will be
happy anded I don't know what light
relief I can offer you AI will solve all
problems says it it must be true
Everything is Awesome techn optimists
yay I think that's that's the current
the co that's the cope yeah not very
persuasive uh Neil as you know we always
end the show with the same question
we'll do a couple of quick questions
from our supporters on locals but before
we go there
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we should
be I think China's nuclear program the
fact that China is building a vast
nuclear Arsenal is a much bigger deal
and it gets very little
coverage you've opened up a can of worms
that I really want to get into but we
have to let you go so head on over to
locals we'll maybe see if we can get a
couple of questions in about that Neil
Ferguson thank you very much it's been
my
pleasure do you think it's hyperbole to
say that if Israel Falls the whole idea
of Western Civilization Falls with
[Music]
it